we often talk about the economy of the
United States and we have a lot of
different questions that we might ask
about the economy but one common one is
what indicators can we look at to tell
us whether the economy is doing well
right now and there's a lot of debate
over what the right answer to that
question is and number two there's a
question that is more forward-looking
which is are there any indicators that
can give us a clue about how the economy
might do in the future and in general
I've said before and the data backs up
that we're generally not very good at
predicting where the economy is going to
go we can sort of generally say that at
a certain point in the next number of
years there's going to be an economic
downturn and we can say that with some
certitude because it tends to always
happen if you look back in history at a
certain point there's always some kind
of downturn but our ability to predict
exactly when it will be is relatively
poor economists aren't particularly good
at it everybody's pretty bad at it
financial advisors aren't particularly
good at it but that doesn't mean there
aren't indicators we can look at that
can provide at least an early warning
sign that certain aspects of the economy
are starting to not look quite so
positive and one important indicator
might not be one you've heard of before
is our people able to afford their car
payments and we have new data which
tells us that a record seven million
Americans are 90 days or more behind on
their car loan payments three months or
more behind and this is a number that's
higher than during the 2008 financial
crisis even adjusted for the population
growth that the country has seen in the
ten years since so a reasonable question
would be okay fine David a record number
of people or thirty are three months
behind on car payments but why does that
matter the reason it matters is that car
payments are a priority for most people
that have a car loan and the reason why
is pretty obvious if you have a car you
probably need the car to either get to
work which allows you to earn money to
pay for your other expenses
or to get to school or to drive your
kids around so for many Americans their
car payment is a top-priority payment
every single month and losing that car
if it becomes repossessed means you
might not be able to go to work which
means you will eventually not be able to
make your rent or mortgage payments and
you can sort of imagine how it has this
cascading negative effect now there are
lots of problems in the auto loan
industry that we can point to there are
more and more of these subprime
financing options which are letting
people buy cars that are way more
expensive than their budgets really
dictate they should be driving there are
record long car loans 84 months I've
even heard of longer loans than that
these are insanely long loans on assets
that depreciate cars depreciate very
quickly particularly in their first few
years you probably should be buying a
cheaper car before you get a car loan
that is 84 months long
predatory rates where people pay
astronomically high interest rates on
their car loans terrible public transit
pushes people to get cars who other my
otherwise might say you know I can just
take public transit to get to work or to
school so there are all these problems
in the car lending industry but that
doesn't change that it's a really bad
sign that a record number of Americans
are three months behind on their car
loans and I don't say this because I'm
worried about automobile manufacturers I
don't say this because I'm worried that
auto lending companies are going to be
affected or that it's bad for the travel
industry if people lose their cars and
won't take road trips or whatever this
is bad because think about the context
we just had quote tax cuts from Donald
Trump and Republicans we have an
exploding deficit we have cheap gas we
have a low federal funds rate we have
historically low unemployment in terms
of the rate we have the stock market
near all-time highs and yet we still
have a record number of people who are
unable to make their car payments and
this relates to broader problems in the
economy cost of living is one
stagnant wages is another health care
spending by individuals and families is
another student loan debt the cost of
education and so when we look at this
indicator we have to realize it's not
about is this going to hurt GM it's more
about why is it that with so many
economic indicators actually looking
fine are we still seeing this degree of
late payments on auto loans and there's
a couple other notable things for people
kind of interested in the car loan
industry there's this common defense
that it's not that problematic for
people to default on car loans because
the car loans are collateralized what
this means is that when a bank gives you
a car loan you were giving them the car
as collateral meaning if you don't pay
the loan or you default on the loan as
it is more often said the lender can
just repossess the car and sell it and
they're fine cars depreciate rapidly so
the idea that that's not a problem is
simply not true yes the car gets
repossessed but the car is worth very
little compared to the original purchase
price number two lenders are more and
more willing to extend loans to people
who probably shouldn't be buying cars
that are that expensive because with GPS
tracking technology lenders are also
more secure in knowing that if the
person defaults they can use the GPS
tracker to just find the car and get it
back that's also a real problem in the
car lending industry that is extending
credit once again to people who should
be having much smaller loans rather than
extending loans over seventy to eighty
four or in some cases I've even heard of
ninety six-month car loans this is the
double-edged sword sort of of technology
but not a good indicator and it is one
that a lot of economists are paying very
very close attention to does this mean
we can predict exactly when the next
downturn is going to be no it doesn't
but it's an important indicator to look
at